สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเรียมวันนี้วันอะไร
คะ
วันนี้วันอังคาร
[เพลง]
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 20 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกันยายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
อีคอะไรคะ
ข้อ 2022
[เพลง]
ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้
บ่าย 2 โมง
32 นาทีค่ะ
บ่ายสองแล้วครูเรียมเป็นยังไงคะวันนี้
สบายดีนะคะ
วันนี้สบายดีค่ะแต่ว่าก็ดมยาดมนิดหน่อย
ก็อาจจะแบบว่าอากาศมันร้อนเนาะทำไมคุณ
หญิงมืดๆค่ะอ๋อลืมเปิดไฟนี่เองไม่เป็นไร
เนาะ
ลืมปิดไฟ
นะคะก็ผู้เรียนสบายดีใช่ไหมใช่อะไรนะคะ
สบายดีเรียมก็แบบอากาศร้อนจริงนะแต่ลิ้ม
ก็เปิดพัดลมเปิดพัดลมแล้วก็ง่วงนอน
[เพลง]
แบบบ่ายๆเนาะบ่ายสองอิ่มๆเปิดพัดลมเย็นๆ
ก็ง่วงนอนครูเรียมง่วงนอนไม่ได้ค่ะวันนี้
เพราะว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยมีเกมจะมาเล่นกับครู
เรียม
เราชอบมาเล่นเกมตอนบ่ายเพราะว่าเรารู้สึก
ง่วง
แต่ว่าเกมอันนี้นะคะครูเรียมเนี่ยก็ต้อง
ฟังดีๆแล้วก็ต้องคิดเพราะว่าเราบอกว่ามัน
เป็นเกมเกี่ยวกับการเอาตัวรอดว่าผู้เรียน
เนี่ยชอบเดินป่าใช่ไหมคะชอบเดินป่าครู
เรียมเนี่ยก็ต้องจะต้องเป็นคนที่เอาตัว
รอดเก่งเพราะว่าบางครั้งอ่ะเราเดินเข้าไป
ในป่ามันไม่มีสัญญาณโทรศัพท์แล้วท่านน้ำ
หมดจะทำยังไง
อาหารหมดทำยังไงเราหลงทางครูเรียมเดิน
แล้วแบบเฮ้ยทำไมไม่มีคนเลย
แล้วครูเรียมจะออกจากป่ายังไงเนี่ยมันคือ
การเอาตัวรอด
อะไรขนาดนั้นนะคะผู้หญิงแค่มีเรื่องมา
เล่าให้ผู้เรียนฟังค่ะครูเลี้ยง
จริงๆมันก็เป็นเรื่องเกี่ยวกับการเดินป่า
เหมือนกันนะ
เพราะว่า
เดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงนะคะ
ครูหญิงจะแชร์หน้าจอใช่ไหมคะ
ยังค่ะยังๆค่ะยังไม่ได้แชร์หน้าจอค่ะแต่
ว่าขยับ
ที่ผู้หญิงจะเล่าให้ผู้เรียนฟังมันขยับ
ไม่ได้นะคะ
โอเคค่ะก็มันจริงๆมันก็เป็นเรื่องราวของ
การเดินป่านะคะก็
มีเด็กผู้ชายอยู่ 1 คน
เขาเนี่ยเดินเข้าไปในป่า
คุณเรียมชอบป่าใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะชอบป่า
ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบเลยนะคะเวลาแบบเข้าไปในป่า
มันจะมีความรู้สึกถึงความน่ากลัวมัน
เหมือนเรามองไม่เห็นอะไรเลยอ่ะ
เห็นต้นไม้ไง
แต่พอเราเงยขึ้นไปบนฟ้าบางครั้งเราก็ไม่
เห็นพระอาทิตย์ไม่มีคนมันเงียบ
รู้สึกน่ากลัวนะ
ละครดูจากในหนังหรือเปล่า
ใช่ค่ะชอบแบบดูแบบพวกเคสอะไรอย่างนี้มัน
จะชอบมีเหตุการณ์อะไรที่มันจะมันจะเกิด
ขึ้นอยู่ในป่าเราก็เลยรู้สึกว่ามันน่า
กลัวเนอะก็เลยไม่ชอบเดินป่านะคะก็เลยไม่
มีสกิลในการเอาตัวรอดแน่ๆเลย
ต้องมาดูกันไม่แน่อาจจะเรียมอาจจะแบบไม่
ได้มีทักษะหรือว่าสกิลในการเอาตัวรอดก็
ได้
โอเคค่ะนักเรียนบอกเมื่อไหร่จะเล่าต่อคะ
หยุดพูดเรื่องตัวเองได้แล้ว
นะคะเขาเดินเข้าไปในป่าแล้วเขาก็ไปเจอกับ
กระท่อมหลังนึงคือกระท่อมมันก็เป็นบ้าน
แบบนึงอ่ะเนาะคือถ้าคิดถึงของประเทศนัก
เรียนเนี่ยก็จะเป็นเหมือนบ้านที่เป็นไม้
ทั้งหมดแล้วก็อยู่ในป่าอย่างนั้นนะคะคือ
ของไทยมันก็ประมาณคล้ายๆกันน่ะเนาะก็เป็น
กระท่อมหลังนึง
ก็ไม่รู้ว่าถ้าครูเรียมนะเอาก่อนที่จะไป
เล่นเกมเลยนะคะถ้าผู้เรียนเนี่ยเดินเข้า
ไปในป่าอาจจะไปเที่ยวไปเดินเล่นอากาศดี
ออกกำลังกายแล้วผู้เรียนก็เห็นกระท่อม
หรือว่าบ้านอยู่หลังนึงเนี่ยมันดูแบบ
เงียบๆนะไม่มีคนเลยอ่ะ
คุณเรียมจะเข้าไปไหม
ไม่ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่เข้านะคะแต่ว่าเด็กผู้ชายคน
นี้
เขาเข้าไปในกระท่อมค่ะ
บอกเขาออกมาค่ะ
ไม่ได้สิถ้าเขาออกมาแล้วกูเรียนจะได้มา
เล่นเกมวันนี้หรอคะ
เขาก็เดินเข้าไปในกระท่อมใช่ไหมเขาก็เปิด
ประตูประตูก็ไม่ได้ล็อคด้วยนะคะแล้วที่
แบบเราไปบิดลูกบิดประตูอ่ะแล้วประตูไม่
ได้ล็อคเราไม่ได้ยินเสียงใครในกระท่อมเลย
อ่ะมันก็ดูน่ากลัวอยู่เหมือนกันเนาะ
ทุกครั้งเลยนะคะที่ผู้หญิงพยายามจะพูด
อะไรเนี่ยนี่ก็คือเอาตัวรอดแล้วไงคะผู้
หญิงไม่ต้องเข้าไปเลย
อันนี้เขาไม่เรียกเอาตัวรอดค่ะอันนี้เขา
เรียกว่าหมีค่ะ
มาๆๆมาต่อดีกว่ามาต่อๆๆนะคะ
ก็เด็กผู้ชายคนนี้เขาก็บิดลูกบิดเนาะ
ประตูเปิดแล้วก็เดินเข้าไปนะคะแล้วเขาก็
ปิดประตู
แล้วประตูเนี่ยมันปิดแบบเราได้ยินเสียง
ว่ามันไม่ใช่ประตูปิดอย่างเดียวอ่ะค่ะครู
เรียมมันปิดแล้วก็มีเสียงแบบแกร๊กก็คือ
มันล็อคจากข้างนอก
เหมือนเราได้ยินเสียงว่ามีคนล็อคประตูจาก
ข้างนอกแล้ว
[เพลง]
ภายในกระท่อมนะคะพอเด็กผู้ชายเขาเปิด
ประตูเข้ามาแล้วเนี่ยข้างในกระท่อมเนี่ย
ก็คือมืดมาก
นี่เข้าไปเดินป่ากี่โมงคะ
มันกระท่อมมันมืดขนาดนั้น
หรือว่าไม่มีหน้าต่างมีหน้าต่างเลย
เออไม่มีแสงเข้าเลยนะคะ
ถามครูเรียมก่อนค่ะ
เหลี่ยมเข้าไปในกระท่อมแล้วมันมืดมากคิด
อะไรคะตอนนั้น
คิดอะไรก็คิดว่า
เอาโทรศัพท์ขึ้นมาแล้วก็เปิดไฟฉาย
แต่ว่าเด็กผู้ชายคนนั้นน่ะเขาไม่มี
โทรศัพท์ค่ะครูเรียม
เขาก็เลยไม่มีไฟฉายในโทรศัพท์นะคะเขาก็
เลยรู้สึกว่ากระท่อมเนี่ยมันมืดมากเขาก็
พยายามใช้มือเพราะว่าเวลามันมืดมากๆเนี่ย
เราจะมองอะไรไม่เห็นใช่ค่ะเก่งมากค่ะเรา
ก็จะใช้มือคลำ
ๆๆเขาก็ใช้มือเนี่ยคลำหา Switch ไฟอยู่
แบบสวิตช์ไฟแบบเปิดปิดไฟมันจะมี
นะคะมันดัง
เขาก็พยายามหาสวิตช์ไฟแล้วเขาก็เจอสวิตช์
ไฟด้วยนะคะครูเรียม
แต่เขาก็พยายามกดเปิดไฟเปิดสวิตช์อ่ะค่ะ
เพราะว่าสวิตช์
เปิดเปิดแล้วก็ปิดแต่เขาพยายามกดแล้วกดๆ
ก็พบว่า
กระท่อมเนี่ย
มีสวิตช์ไฟไฟเนี่ยมันเปิดไม่ติดเพราะว่า
มันไม่มีไฟฟ้า
[เพลง]
ก็คืออินเทอร์เน็ตใช้ไม่ได้นะคะ
ไม่มีไฟเพราะว่าแบบอาจจะไฟดับใช่ไหมไฟดับ
พอไฟดับก็คือเปิดไฟไม่ได้ปิดเปิดปิดไฟก็
ไม่ได้อ่ะค่ะไฟก็ไม่มีนะคะพอตอนนั้นเขาก็
ตกใจแล้วเพราะว่าเดินมาที่ประตูประตูที่
เขาเข้ามาเนี่ยเขาก็ออกไม่ได้ไงประตู
มันล็อคไปแล้ว
แล้วจู่ๆค่ะเขาก็ได้ยินเสียงเสียงนึง
เสียงดังในกระท่อมเสียงอะไรค่ะ
คุณเรียมคิดว่าเสียงอะไรคะเสียงตุ๊กแก
ผู้หญิงนะ
คะตุ๊กแกไม่ใช่ค่ะมันเป็นเสียงของผู้ชาย 1
คนมันเป็นเสียงพูดของผู้ชาย 1 คน
เรียนรู้ไหมคะว่าเขาพูดอะไร
ใครน่ะ
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ใครน่ะเขารู้อยู่แล้วค่ะเขา
ไม่ได้ถามว่าคุณเป็นใครเขาไม่ได้ถามเขา
บอกว่า
เธอติดอยู่ที่กระท่อมนี้แล้ว
แต่เธอยังมีวิธีที่จะออกได้นะ
[เพลง]
แต่มันมีแค่วิธีเดียวเท่านั้นก็คือเดี๋ยว
บี๋จะแชร์รูปนะคะอะไรหรอ
[เพลง]
ผู้ชายคนนั้นเนี่ยเขาก็บอกว่า
มันจะมีวิธีออกจากกระท่อมได้วิธีเดียวก็
คือเธอเห็นประตูนั้นไหม
ไม่เห็นมืดมาก
เห็นสิคะ
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันมันมืดนะคะ
ต้องบอกว่า
หันไปทางซ้ายของเธอเธอจะเห็นว่ามีประตู
อยู่ 3 บานมันจะมีแค่ประตูเดียวเท่านั้น
ที่เธอจะเปิดออกไปแล้วก็จะออกไปข้างนอก
ได้
ผู้ชายเสียงที่เขาได้ยินเนี่ยนะคะก็บอก
ว่า
ประตูที่ 1 ก็คือเปลี่ยนสีหน่อยนะคะ
ประตูที่ 1
แป๊บนึงนะคะ
เล็กไปหน่อยประตูที่ 1 เนี่ยนะคะ
คือต้องเลือกนะต้องเลือก 1 ประตูนะคะแต่
คนที่อยู่ที่บ้านเสียงของผู้ชายคนนั้น
เนี่ยเขาจะบอกว่าแต่ละประตูเนี่ยเราเปิด
ไปเราจะเจอกับอะไร
เขาก็บอกว่าประตูที่ 1 เนี่ยมีงูพิษใช่
ไหมงูเนี่ยมีงูพิษอยู่หลายตัวถ้าคุณเปิด
ไปแล้วก็อาจจะเดินอาจจะเดินนะคะอาจจะโดน
งูกัดแล้วก็พิษของงูเนี่ยก็วิ่งๆๆๆๆแล้ว
ก็ตายอันนี้คือประตูที่ 1
ประตูที่ 2
อ่าประตูที่ 2 เนี่ยนะคะมีเก้าอี้อันนี้
อันนี้คือเก้าอี้ไฟฟ้าแล้วก็มีผู้ชายที่
เป็นเจ้าของกระท่อมเนี่ยยืนรออยู่กับ
เก้าอี้ไฟฟ้า
พาเด็กผู้ชายเนี่ยเปิดประตูที่ 2 ก็อาจจะ
ไปนั่งอยู่ที่นี่
แล้วก็โดนไฟฟ้าช็อตตายนะคะอันนี้คือประตู
ที่ 2
แล้วก็ประตูที่ 3 ประตูที่ 3 เนี่ยนะคะ
ถ้าเปิดออกไปก็จะมีสิงโต
สิงโตที่มันหิวหิวมากๆเพราะว่าไม่ได้กิน
อาหารมาหลายวันเนี่ยรออยู่ซึ่ง
หญิงเลิกแชร์แล้วนะคะมันจะมีประตูบาน
เดียวเท่านั้นที่เด็กผู้ชายเขาเปิดไปเจอ
เปิด
ไปแล้ว
จะไม่ตายจะหนีออกไปได้นะคะซึ่งครูเรียม
เนี่ยนะคะคุณหญิงก็เลยถามว่าถ้าครูเรียม
เป็นเด็กผู้ชายครูเรียมจะหนีออกจาก
กระท่อมนี้เนี่ยโดยเปิดประตูบานไหนบานที่
1 ที่ไปเจองูพิษบานที่ 2 ที่มีเก้าอี้ไฟ
ฟ้าหรือว่าบานที่ 3 ที่มีสิงโตที่หิวมากๆ
ดูง่ายมาก
มันมีขนาดนั้นเลยหรอคะผู้หญิงนั้นเล่ามา
ตั้งนานครูเรียงฟังจบปุ๊บครูหญิงค่ะเอา
อะไรมาเล่นกับครูเรียมค่ะนี่ไงเด็กผู้ชาย
เนี่ยต้องเอาตัวรอดต้องคนการที่เราจะเอา
ตัวรอดได้เราต้องคิดเร็วๆนะใช่
ผู้เรียนเลือกประตูบานไหนคะเปิดประตูบาน
ไหนคะเตรียมเลือกเปิดประตูบานที่ 2
ทำไมอ่ะประตูบานที่ 2 เนี่ยมีเก้าอี้ไฟ
ฟ้าแล้วก็มีผู้ชายที่เป็นเจ้าของกระท่อม
เนี่ยรอที่จะฆ่าครูเรียมอยู่นะ
ไม่กลัวค่ะเขาจะใช้คนนะ
เขาจะใช้เก้าอี้ไฟฟ้าค่าเหลี่ยมหรอ
นั่งที่เก้าอี้ไฟฟ้าแล้วเขาก็จะเอาให้ไฟ
ฟ้าช็อตครูเรียมตายนะ
ไฟดับอยู่นะคะคุณหญิง
ยกเก้าอี้ฟาดเขาก็ได้นะคะ
ครูเรียมเนี่ยเลือกประตูที่ 2 ใช่ไหม
ใช่ก่อนครูหญิงจะเฉลยนะคะว่าครูเรียน
เนี่ยเลือกถูกหรือเปล่านักเรียนที่ฟังมา
เนี่ยฟังคุยอีกเล่ามานะคะนักเรียนคิดว่า
นักเรียนจะเลือกประตูไหนหรือว่านักเรียน
คิดว่าประตูไหนที่เด็กผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยจะ
ปลอดภัยแล้วก็ออกจากข้างนอกได้
พอนะคะเฉลย
ก็คือเด็กผู้ชาย
เขาควรจะเปิดประตูที่มี
ที่ที่มีเก้าอี้ไฟฟ้าค่ะประตูที่ 2 ผู้
เรียนเก่งมากเพราะว่าไม่มีไฟถูกไหมคะคุณ
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่ามันไม่มีไฟฟ้ามันก็คือ
เก้าอี้ธรรมดา
ทำอะไรเราไม่ได้ถึงแม้ว่าจะมีผู้ชายที่
เป็นเจ้าของกระท่อมอยู่เด็กผู้ชายอาจจะ
สู้ไม่ได้แต่เขาก็จับเด็กมานั่งที่
เก้าอี้ก็นั่งเฉยๆเหมือนครูหญิงนั่งสอน
อยู่เนี่ยนะคะก็ไม่มีไฟฟ้าใช่ไหมถ้าเปิด
ประตูที่ 1 ไปเจอกับงู
ถ้าเราโดนงูกัดงูมีพิษด้วยอ่ะค่ะ
1 ตัวก็ตายแล้วแต่เราไม่รู้ว่าเราจะไป
เจองูกี่ตัว
ใช่
[เพลง]
หรือว่าถ้าเปิดประตูที่ 3 ใช่ไหมไปเจอกับ
สิงโต
เราจะสู้สิงโตได้หรอหรือหญิงบอกว่าสิงโต
หิวด้วย
หิวมากด้วยค่ะแล้วสิงโตเนี่ยกินคนใช่ไหม
ใช่กินคนได้
กินคนได้นะคะเพราะฉะนั้นก็ประตูที่ 2 ค่ะ
เพราะว่าเปิดไปก็ไปเจอคนเนาะอย่างน้อยก็
คุยกันรู้เรื่องอ่ะนะคะแบบโอ้ยจะทำอะไรผม
เลยนะครับถ้าสู้ไม่ไหวอ่ะนะคะแล้วก็ประตู
ที่ 2 ค่ะเห็นไหมเราต้อง
เวลาที่เราอยู่ในอันตราย
เด็กผู้ชายเนี่ยเขาอยู่ในอันตรายใช่ไหมคะ
เพราะว่าเข้าไปในกระท่อมเสร็จแล้วก็ออก
ไม่ได้
มีตัวเลือกให้เลือก 3 ตัวทีเนี้ยก็ต้อง
คิดดีๆใช่
ฟังดีๆว่าเราจะออกไปจากที่นี่ได้ยังไงเรา
จะเอาตัวรอดได้ยังไงเขาก็บอกว่าเวลาที่
เราอยู่ในอะไรนะคะสถานการณ์อันตรายแบบนี้
เนาะเราต้อง
ไม่ตกใจอ่ะใช่ไหมไม่กลัวแล้วครูหญิงล่ะคะ
เคยอยู่ในสถานการณ์ที่แบบคล้ายๆแบบนี้ไหม
ที่แบบต้องเอาตัวรอดอยู่ดีๆครูหญิงจะไป
ที่ที่แบบบางทีเรารู้อยู่แล้วว่ามัน
อันตราย
เดี๋ยวว่าส่วนน้อยมากๆเลยนะ
เพราะว่าบางครั้งเราอาจจะไม่ได้เอาตัวรอด
จากอันตรายแบบนี้แต่เหมือนที่ผู้หญิงบอก
อ่ะค่ะว่าบางทีเราแบบเราไปเดินป่าอย่าง
นี้เราอาจจะเพลินแล้วเราอาจจะแบบว่าเดิน
จนมันมืดแล้วเราก็แบบเฮ้ยเราอยู่ที่ไหน
เราจะอยู่ได้ยังไงเราจะเอาน้ำที่ไหนหรือ
ว่าไปเดินป่าอย่างเงี้ยน้ำหมด
เราจะต้องดูว่าเอออะไรที่เราจะกินได้ทำ
ยังไงให้เราออกมาจากอันตรายได้อ่ะเนาะ
ส่วนใหญ่ทุกคนไม่ได้อยากไปอยู่ในที่ที่
อันตรายใช่แต่ว่าเรื่องที่ครูหญิงเล่ามา
เรื่องที่ไปเดินป่าแล้วน้ำหมดน่ะเรียมเคย
เจอนะ
เดินป่าแบบตอนเด็กอ่ะเป็นแบบซนมากดื้อมาก
เขาบอกว่าห้ามเข้าป่า
แต่เรียมเดินเข้าไป
ไปใช่ไหมคะใช่อยากไปอยากรู้แบบทำไมเขาถึง
ห้าม
มันไม่ดีนะคะมันไม่ดีทุกคนรู้แล้วว่ามัน
ไม่ดีแต่เล่าให้ฟังก็คือสิ่งที่เรียมเคย
ทำแล้วมันเกิดขึ้นแล้วแล้วก็แบบตอนนั้นก็
คือตกใจมากเพราะว่าเดินไปเอาน้ำไปแค่ขวด
เดียวแล้วเดินไกลมาก
ภูเขา
ข้ามภูเขา
จริงแล้วแบบพอกลับมาพอเดินกลับมาได้ก็คือ
แบบ
รู้สึกแบบรู้สึกผิดอ่ะ
ที่แบบเราไปแบบนั้น
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าแบบทำไมแบบเด็กๆเนอะต้อง
รู้ต้องรู้วิธีในการเอาตัวรอดคือเราไม่
อาจจะไม่ช่วยตัวเองเหมือนกับว่าเราก็ไม่
รู้หรอกว่าเราต้องทำยังไงแต่เราต้องทำยัง
ไงก็ได้ให้คนเนี่ยมาช่วยเราให้ได้ใช่ไหม
แบบเหมือนประเทศไทยก็มีข่าวบ่อยๆใช่ไหม
ว่าเด็กอยู่ในรถแล้วก็เสียชีวิตว่าเราไม่
ได้สอนให้เด็กรู้จักวิธีเอาตัวรอดว่าทำ
ยังไงคนจะเห็นว่าเฮ้ยเราอยู่ในอันตรายนะ
มันเป็นเรื่องที่ค่อนข้างจะสำคัญอยู่
เหมือนกันนะคะเพราะว่าเหมือนเด็กผู้ชายคน
นี้ใช่ไหมที่ผู้หญิงเล่าอ่ะคือเขาก็ไม่
ได้คิดอะไรอ่ะเขาก็ไม่ได้คิดว่าเขาจะมา
เจอบ้านที่เขาออกไม่ได้มันเป็นเหตุการณ์
ที่เราไม่ได้รู้มาก่อนน่ะแต่เมื่อมันเกิด
ขึ้นแล้วเราจะทำยังไงดีล่ะให้เราไม่ตาย
เหมือนคุณเหมือนคุณเรียมคุณเรียมก็ต้อง
คิดใช่ไหมเดินเข้าไปในป่าแล้ว
มาทางไหน
ฉันจะไปต่ออีกไหมใช่ไหมคะมันก็ต้องคิดไม่
ใช่แบบตกใจแล้วก็วิ่งอันนี้คงกลับบ้านไม่
ได้แน่ๆใช่แล้วค่ะก็เป็นเหมือนกันเลยกับ
แบบสิ่งที่ครูหญิงเอามาให้เล่นเกมในวัน
นี้
ใช่ค่ะก็เป็นเกมสนุกๆเนาะเอามาเล่นนะคะก็
วันนี้คิดว่าหมดเวลาแล้วหรือเปล่าใช่ค่ะ
หมดเวลาแล้วค่ะครูหญิงเอ้าเราแค่แบบเกม
เดียวเองอ่ะยังนึกว่าจะมีต่อ
มีเกมเดียวก็พอแล้วค่ะเดี๋ยวครูเรียมตอบ
ได้หมด
ชอบมากเอามาวันละเกมก็พอนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยว
เรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดี
ค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนบ๊าย
บาย